NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RODRIC RABBAH: OK, great.
So a lot of effort into
making this course, and we
hope you've had fun.
It's been a lot of support
from Sony, IBM, Toshiba.
A lot of on demand help
from people at IBM and Sony,
trying to debug problems,
even up to the last minute.
So we're very thankful for that.
And we hope in return that
you really enjoyed the course,
and it was really fun.
So looking forward to
the course evaluations.
So just want to tell
you a little bit
about some opportunities ahead.
I've passed out these brochures
for the cell broadband engine
challenge, Beyond Gaming.
And this is a IBM sponsored
event, where you really
can compete in two different
challenges, and in one of them
you can win really
seriously cool t-shirts.
That's actually lifted
directly from the online link.
So the competition starts
February 5 at midnight.
And you have to pass an online
quiz, of which I expect all
of you should be able to pass.
And hopefully, you will
compete and at least get
a seriously cool t-shirt.
The second challenge, which is
potentially more interesting,
just because there's
a $10K grand prize--
there's also a $7K second
prize, and some serious money
for at least three
or four prizes.
You can look at information
in the brochures.
According to the
information, you'll
find it requires some serious
coding skills on your part.
But I certainly
expect all of you
to be able to be well
primed at this point,
especially since you've
learned about cell hands on,
and you've discovered all
the pitfalls on your own.
It would make for a very good
competition on your part.
There are different categories.
Sorry, it's three
categories, not four.
Application solutions-- so some
of things, some of the people
have done more application
oriented thing could fit,
or you can sort of take
what you've learned,
apply it to financial
services if you
have interest in
that, medical imaging,
electronic design, automation,
things of that sort.
Operating systems--
I'm not sure if that's
particularly relevant
to a lot of people here.
I'm not sure if that's
in their interest area,
but programmability.
So certainly the
streaming framework
that one of the software
radio projects tried to do
would fit onto that,
some of the work
that the Ray Tracer
team did, in terms
of coming up with their
own interface for graphics
could certainly fit.
So I urge you to consider
competing in these.
There's probably a lot of fame
and fortune to be had here.
So we had our own competition.
And what you're going to get are
some seriously cool trophies,
since we don't have t-shirts.
So Mary was very--
could have had t-shirts.
I didn't want to compete
with IBM directly.
So for the winning team, you
will get this seriously awesome
looking trophy, which has a
little imprint on the front
that says first place, 6.189.
And you're also going to
get a $150 gift certificate,
I think we announced this at
the beginning it of the course.
I'm also working
with people at IBM
on arranging a one
day trip to IBM T.J.
Watson Research Center,
for the winning team
to present their winning
project, do a demo,
and then meet with people
at IBM who are doing really
cool, interesting research.
And it should be a fun day.
And certain people
at IBM have been
very excited about
hearing what's going on
in this project, in this class.
And so it'll be a
good, fun opportunity,
I think, all around.
OK, so I'm going to work my
way up to the first prize.
I think in terms of the
complexity of the project
handled, certainly
Speech Synthesis probably
took on the most
complex-- certainly
in terms of the
software that they used,
and then maybe that
bogged them down a little.
So there's probably
something to be
said in terms of starting
from scratch versus taking
complex infrastructure
and re-engineering it
for parallelism.
I think you've
discovered firsthand
how hard that really is.
And this is a big problem
for parallel computing.
There's a lot of legacy
software out there
that eventually might
have to be ported
to parallel architectures.
How do you do it?
You pointed out, code
is not well documented.
Tools are lacking.
So what do you do?
So you've stumbled on a really
seriously important problem
facing a lot of people
in the industry.
The most synchronization issues.
We believe the guys who are
doing the Battery Simulations
and modeling sort of
the chemical reactions
certainly ran into a lot
of synchronization issues,
just because of the dependent
nature of the computation.
Next up on the list would be for
the most parallel programming
challenges.
So not only did they run into
issues with synchronization,
but certainly discovered
problems with races.
And I think they're the only
team who have successfully
hung their PlayStation
3 several times,
and required a reboot
quite a few times.
OK.
So next, best effort awards.
These guys should really be
highlighted, because they
worked largely on their own.
Is that true?
Yes.
Yeah, and that's certainly true.
And there was certainly
a lot of people
who were impressed by the
Global Illumination stuff
yesterday, and sort
of mentioned that.
And what I'm hoping to do
is take the judges' feedback
and sort of summarize
that for each team,
so you can have some
constructive criticism back
that might be helpful.
Molecular Dynamic
Simulation work
that you heard
about today, I think
certainly a valiant effort
on his part, as well.
The most complete project,
I think this would probably
be Backgammon Tutor's project.
I think in terms of scope
it was well defined,
in terms of what they
actually completed.
I think they came out
with a really cool game.
My money was on them all
along to actually win
the first prize.
But I think the Ray Tracing team
actually blew everybody away
with their demo.
And I think they
were a clear winner.
They really tackled sort
of their paralyzation,
descendizing.
They had a really cool
frame buffer demo,
so they figured out
how to actually write
to the frame buffer
and do that simulation,
or do the graphics rendering.
And I think some mumbling
about a real cool demo
that they've gotten
working overnight.
So we'll try to set up
over in [? Stoddart, ?]
where we have pizza, and you
guys can take a look at that.
So with that, I'll hand out
the certificates and the awards
offline.
But you've at this
point been Cell-ified.
And the cake is in the
back says, Congratulations
on your Cell-ification.
So--
Resistance is futile.
That's right.
So thanks a lot for
taking the course.
I think we've learned
a lot as instructors.
I'm hoping to do this again
with Saman next year, next IAP,
and maybe eventually turn it
into a regular semester course.
I think there's a lot of
things we can do better,
and hopefully you've told us
some ideas of how to do that.
So with that, thanks, and start
enjoying cake in the back.